transparencia internacional señaló que
las protestas sobre el resultado y esto
entre comillas de un dramático
endeudamiento público que se destina a
lo que aparentan ser usos discrecionales
movidos por objetivos políticos y por su
parte los sindicatos piden austeridad
explíquenos qué es lo que ocurre en el
gobierno de laurentino cortizo
lamentablemente tenemos que parar una
crisis de credibilidad tengo un
liderazgo que no está resolviendo los
problemas no de reciente data sino de
los últimos 30 años tenemos una
situación inflacionaria que no habíamos
vivido antes simplemente llegar a 4.7
por ciento de inflación es raro para
para para una economía dolarizada sin
banco central sin un banco de último
recurso pues depende mucho del manejo de
la disciplina fiscal y nos ha hecho
falta nos ha hecho falta apegarnos
precisamente a la utilización de esos
fondos que vinieron de deuda un momento
dado la pandemia nos ubicó en ayudarnos
mucho más y el desempleo rampante nos
está copiando de una manera inusual creo
que es una coyuntura muy inusual para
más no está acostumbrado a este tipo de
manifestaciones y embargos este amor
popular de un país que está habiendo
medicamentos con precios exorbitantes
sin algún tipo de plan específico para
controlar los los precios en los insumos
alimenticios también se han disparado de
manera descontrolada y todo eso pues nos
golpea de manera importante
especialmente la clase media la clase
trabajadora
casi la mitad de la población está en un
grado de informalidad enqelab la
población productiva a un grado de
informalidad pienso más del peor de los
mensajes ante esa situación el país
espera algún tipo de control en el gasto
pero también que vaya de la mano de
acciones concretas de un plan
aparentemente hay una ausencia de plan y
esperemos que eso cambie los próximos
días para precisamente apaciguar el
clamor popular que está en las calles
como nos evitan para hay muchos años y
ante esta coyuntura inusual como usted
la llama explíquenos qué tan efectivas
son las medidas de austeridad que
prometió el presidente cortizo
en el corto plazo es muy probable que
tome mucho tiempo no es fácil reducir la
planilla estatal el estado se ha
convertido en un gran contratado de un
gran contratante una agencia
prácticamente de empleo 280 mil personas
para un estado tan pequeño como el
nuestro con un presupuesto de 25 mil
millones de dólares es exagerado reducir
en un 10% estamos hablando casi 30 mil
personas que estarían engrosando las
filas de los desempleados no es tan
fácil sin embargo las medidas inmediatas
de gastos de contención para tomar un
duro golpe un futuro dolor para aquellas
personas que están más golpeadas en
panamá ya una ineficiencia estatal pero
también hay
asignaciones a veces de índole política
de botines que se han identificado
diferentes instituciones para el manejo
político precisamente estamos a
proximidad de un brillo electoral y eso
complica mucho la situación porque se
convierte entonces en un elemento en una
herramienta de contratación a través del
clientelismo que tanto daño nos ha hecho